good morning John for Christmas from her
mom Catherine received a log book that
once contained records from her
grandmother's hair salon after she had
kids though she turned it into a recipe
book pasting in recipes from newspapers
and magazines from the 40s and 50s they
are interesting so catherine and i
decided to try a few of them out the
results were mixed here is our recipe
one golden rabbit you make it with two
Campbell's soups stir well one can
Campbell's cheddar cheese soup gradually
blend in one can Campbell's tomato soup
add 1/4 cup milk heat stirring or over
crackers or toast mmm
good plan yeah it's all flavor I have
endured myself
I got too excited about my golden rabbit
doesn't it look like a golden rabbit
this is not on the list of things that I
want to eat again the predominant flavor
is crackers well I do like crackers it
grows on you you're still hungry just
add more crackers serve it with half a
raw potato recipe number two popovers in
a bowl dump 1 cup on sifted flour 1/2
teaspoon salt 2 eggs just break them
over the bowl and drop them in so
they're staring at you with their big
yellow eyes one cup beat this with an
egg beater till it's just mixed now fill
the cups half full and set the cookie
sheet in the 450 degree oven you will
have 6 splendid popovers so golden-brown
and exuberant Lea puffed up that it's
almost embarrassing
I kind of burned them yeah no fish like
a breath northern biscuit and down with
this yeah I'd like to try them again
Coleman whole milk no one's got a hole
no ha ha ha recipe number three beer
dressing mix mayonnaise and mustard
together Adam horseradish and gradually
stir in beer I mean it's not good I let
it mustard that much though recipe
number four Mexican chop suey 1/2 pound
ground beef fried in butter when
possible
1 cup sliced fresh tomatoes 1 medium
sweet pepper 1/2 cup chopped onion 1/2
cup chopped celery 1 cup milk 1
tablespoon flour fry the meat slowly
over low heat then remove the meat
leaving the juices to which should be
added a vegetable ingredient simmer
until tender add tomatoes after which
add milk mixed with flour and simmer
again until mixture begins to thicken
like gravy then combine with meat and
serve immediately you seem really
unexcited about this one said serve
immediately so it can't dilly-dally this
is probably the best it's ever gonna be
I have a suggestion for improving it
huge amounts of salt I'm gonna eat more
so much better right now you're wasting
salt I may be over salt in mind yeah you
really want to town on it definite if
you were gonna name this dish what would
you call how easily is inspired by
Chinese food and Mexican food
what no it's like a Cleveland chowder
recipe number 5 orange cranberry relish
mould dissolve gelatin and boiling water
add orange juice and chill until
consistency of unbeaten egg white cut
orange and quarters removed seeds and
put through a food chopper add ground
orange cranberry sauce a celery and nuts
2 gelatin mixture and turn into a 1
quart mold chill until firm
unmold to serve it's like a : o it's
like coming across just some sand in
your food do not serve your friends or
family this why does jello even still
exist
this is what you get our crazy high
school board what are the hospital like
where else does anyone have jello what
have we learned about Dictys food
Katherine would you rather live today oh
yeah
but I think that there may be there may
be some wisdom sorry not in there Helen
Thanks
Thank You Helen that's my grandmother's
name yes not Helen Lance thanks to Helen
Hunt food thanks Catherine for being in
a video with me thank you for watching
and John I'll see you on Tuesday
you got a lot of cleaning up to do baby
have fun